foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get started with Mr O'Leary are we
at the bottom of the market no not yet
but we're getting close you know we were
fribulating right now trying to figure
out what the earnings next year are
going to look like and so every time you
have a rally like this you've had
extended rally multiple days now to the
upside it's because the belief in the
market is that the FED is finally going
to slow after this next 75 basis points
and kind of wait and see what happened
we got a little signal from that up in
the Canadian Market where they decided
not to increase the sort of broadcast
amount they went 50 basis points of
instead of 75 showing an idea of a you
know a moderation if you want to call it
that now normally we do not take signals
from other countries but Canada being
the giant trading partner it is just
North of the Border it's the first time
in decades I've ever seen anybody wake
up and look at what the Bank of Canada
was doing and that's what happened this
week and it actually forwarded this this
Theory this philosophy that that maybe
the FED is going to pause
now do you think this is potentially a
blink of the FED in the face of or if if
the FED here did pause would they be
blinking in the face of inflation giving
up essentially saying look we've been
saying two percent for years that we're
trying to get back to two percent now uh
but we're not going to make it there
quickly let's just give it time and not
be so aggressive because we realize
we're just going to push the economy
into a depression if we do push for two
percent you have to remember the most
hated man on Earth is always the chair
of the FED regardless of who they are
man or woman everybody hates the FED
everybody second guess the FED everybody
says they're doing the wrong thing all
of the time you can't make anybody happy
when you're the Fed chair and that's
exactly what's happening here he's
trying to in this case in Pal's case
engineer a soft Landing which is near
impossible no one's ever seen that
happen however data coming out this
morning proves that we are not yet in a
recession everybody kind of knows that
just by the feeling of the consumer
being so strong and so for the first
time in a long time people are thinking
wow maybe he can pull this off and we
would know some time in Q2 next year
that he could actually bring in a soft
landing slow down inflation after all
all he needs and the fed the FED in
aggregate needs the board itself needs
is some indication that the the rate of
increase of inflation is slowing that's
the key right now and so we don't have
that quite yet there's a narrative in
the market I want people to understand
this and how CPI data is gathered so
much 40 percent of CPI data is Housing
Shelter and shelter is a very slow index
and so it takes up to 18 months to
actually have an effect on it but people
in different markets are starting to see
rent rates slow or flatten or housing
prices flatten so really what we're
probably doing in the CPI number right
now is over reporting inflation and that
narrative has been coming in with with
Professor Siegel who's been talking
about this ad nauseam for the last six
weeks but you know he has a point you
can't deny the fact that 40 percent of
CPI is shelter and maybe we're over
calculating it now people do this all
the time and I'm guilty of it right now
trying to say well here's why we
shouldn't believe this number it's just
more fed beating and more fed hating and
more you know telling the FED what to do
and the truth is they don't give a damn
they don't listen they have their own
mandate they're going to do what they're
going to do and I say that'll be 75
basis points coming to a theater near
you in the next few days
got it so do you think they're looking
at these leading indicators that we've
hit Peak rental inflation and that that
component is going to start reducing
that sort of core inflation that so far
has been broadening and increasing I
mean we still haven't seen transitory we
were hoping it'd be transitory before
the war then we were hoping to be
transitory by Q3 of this year now it's
like okay maybe it'll be transitory
sometime next year well I've come to the
conclusion because I have my own index
to look at which is my 50 plus private
companies that 50 of this inflation is
actually because of supply chain that
still hasn't been fixed de-globalization
I'll give you just a case study I've
used it so many times let's say I'm
making gym equipment in Fargo North
Dakota where I am and prior to the
pandemic we used to buy all of our metal
our barbells our screws some of the
infrastructure for the benches from Asia
from China from Vietnam from other
countries where it was 30 percent
cheaper we can't get those supplies
anymore partly because the ship that has
it on it is stuck at La Port yes it's
still a problem La Port has not been
fixed yet and so we are forced to go buy
that steel made here domestically now
whether that's a good thing a bad thing
we can debate that to the cows come home
however it's 33 percent more expensive
so we take those barbells and those
benches mark them up 33 percent sell
them into an ever increasing demand
Market our sales have not slowed but
it's 30 percent more expensive that my
friends is inflation and it's not going
to change until I can buy those barbells
again in Asia at 30 percent less which
is no time soon so the fact is that
inflation is self-inflicted by the fact
that we are starting to slow down in
cooperation with global suppliers we're
fighting with the Chinese we're cutting
off their chips they're reciprocating
all of that stuff is occurring and on
top of that people are concerned about
domestic supplies of things like semis
and oil and gas because it's the only
thing you can count on you don't want to
be begging handed cap with foreign
dictators like Venezuela are going to
see the Saudis and asking them to
increase production when they're just
not listening and so at the end of the
day we have this transition occurring
and that's part of the inflation number
the economy itself though proven Again
by numbers today is doing very very well
that's because again I'm speculating 6.7
trillion dollars which of cash was
printed in the last 30 months still
sitting in the checking accounts of the
consumer and he and she are spending it
yeah absolutely yeah the fact that the
personal savings rate is still positive
is is remarkable but you're right it's
being supported on travel spending it's
being supported just on General spending
across the board now you bring up this
Narrative of uh the deglobalization
that's happened because of supply chain
issues a lot of folks have come to this
argument that we should just stay
deglobalized and never essentially
re-globalize do you think that's
impossible in a capitalistic world to
just have localized Supply chains and
just continue to be cut off I mean we've
been fighting with China for decades uh
do you think we'll end up re-globalizing
um I don't think it's possible to
de-globalize and I'll tell you why
there's certain product categories once
they become Commodities or better
manufactured in low-cost countries and
you know the idea that you shouldn't
manufacture socks in Vietnam because of
some protectionism or the fact that
you'd rather pay five times more for
socks that makes no sense whatsoever yet
if you're building a new chip that
actually can fuel AI artificial
intelligence yeah I can see I'd rather
do that domestically and and keep that
away from our economic competitors like
China who don't want to play in a Level
Playing Field unless they're willing to
cooperate and that's the leverage we
have over them so you know different
product categories and I would argue
energy we should remain self-sufficient
that was a mistake the administration
made you know prior to the election the
country was completely independent in
terms of energy production oil and gas
and obviously High plans for shutdown
policy change and I think that this
current Administration realized as they
went too fast too soon and now we have
to Pedal back and I'm not trying to play
politics but it'll be reflected in the
midterms in just a couple of weeks and I
think what we'll have after that would
be very welcome by investors it would be
total gridlock in Washington that is a
wonderful thing the pause that refreshes
no more bills no more spending let's
take a break for a while and then do
jump ball in the election you know 24
months later and I think that's a really
good outcome why many people like me are
optimistic
that's interesting yeah of course you're
referring to the shutting down of the
Keystone Pipeline by the Biden
Administration on day one of him taking
office and what I think is fascinating
is this idea that grid you just said it
gridlock is wonderful so this is really
because when nothing gets done markets
can just take into account the earnings
that we're expecting and not have to
worry about intervention and that brings
up though this idea of the inflation
reduction act which according to Wharton
doesn't actually reduce inflation but it
has some benefits for the EV sector
what's your take on the inflation
reduction act would you be increasing
your allocation to some of these energy
plays that that could potentially stand
to benefit from that I think that act is
very inflationary I think the idea of
forgiving student debt is very
inflationary and Incredibly unfair to
Generations who were burdened with that
debt or in fact couldn't even go to
college because they couldn't take on
that debt I have never seen an act more
Un-American than forgiving student debt
and I hope that get stuck in litigation
and gets reversed it's outrageous what's
going on there and that's extremely
inflationary and that has nothing to do
with politics that's just bad policy you
know doing nothing is always an option
that never happens in government until
there's total gridlock which we're going
to get assuming the house flips nobody
knows what the Senate is going to do yet
it's jump ball but bottom line is
gridlock is a great thing it's a good
thing politicians can't get any bills
done and nothing happens which is a
great option a great option because it's
a form of certainty in the market and
we've had so much Printing and money so
many bills so much bad policy regardless
of what side of the aisle you're on and
I just detailed my own personal opinion
about student debt which I think is just
the more I think about it the more my
blood boils it's just so unfair but at
the end of the day all that stuff gets
shut down and that is what I'm looking
forward to and very encouraged by
now some people might respond to you uh
just on that note and say hey well isn't
it unfair what outrageous tuitions are
being charged for college and then folks
might not be able to get a job that
actually pays them enough to pay off
their student debt what would you say to
somebody who says that it's a fair
comment let's work on that problem but
let's not forgive One cohort's debt when
Generations passed never got that
opportunity this idea of free money for
just the select is absolutely
Un-American that is not what built this
democracy it's just outrageous and and
the idea that you just pick one cohort
they're the special ones that don't have
to pay for their debt I agree with you
Education costs are too high let's work
on that problem let's figure out a new
way to approach that let's use
technology to maybe make it a More Level
Playing Field but not giving one cohort
just one the special ones they get their
debt forgiven outrageous
well hey if you wanted a another
stimulus check you could always move to
California where Governor Gavin Newsom
is now providing inflation relief checks
uh what what's your take on Governor
Gavin Newsom providing these to people
earning up to five hundred thousand
dollars a year well you know there are
some ideas that are bad ideas and
there's some ideas that are stupid ideas
very rarely can you combine both but
that's what you've got here a really bad
and stupid idea because you're just
fueling inflation now the great news
about what's going on between state to
state is we're finally getting a
competition
idiot management states are losing
taxpayers losing capital from companies
and lots of movement out of them
California New York New Jersey
Massachusetts people are leaving there
and companies are leaving there and
moving to places like Colorado North
Dakota Florida Montana I am doing my
fair part of that too I'm moving
companies out of California that place
is great to visit but not fit for
business I would never invest a dime
there same with New York I've moved a
big project out of New York to Norway a
data center there because New York
policy is unstable and I spent a fair
amount of my time on the hill showing
these examples to lawmakers on both
sides of the aisle I'm just one investor
but we make aggregate decisions millions
of them buy the day and those places are
uncompetitive Elizabeth warns
Massachusetts is not a place for
business and that's why they keep trying
to overtax and overtax their past 50
percent California past 50 percent New
York City's past 50 percent no problem
people are fungible they move they're
not stupid why would you go sit in a
cubicle in a New York high-rise when you
can be in great weather in Miami and
save a ton of money on taxes exactly
what everybody's doing
well on that note I I'm curious on your
thoughts on uh sort of scaling
single-family real estate investment
that's something that I've launched a
startup on we've raised over 25 million
dollars it's house hack is the name of
it and we're looking to buy
single-family homes and potentially
multi-family and then rent them out with
a combination of short long-term rentals
so we have a nice mix of sort of cash
flow in various different markets so
South Florida Texas and and maybe even
uh I know you might not like it but but
even some California uh to to diversify
the the portfolio what's your take uh
would you follow the jobs would you
follow where the new offices are being
built like in Miami in Brickell you've
got not that people like them on social
media but Citadel investing over a
billion dollars in Miami
you know I've I've been uh quite an
investor in the Miami market now for six
years in terms of my allocation of real
estate Investments I I would say one
thing about real estate That's Unique is
a sector now normally portfolio Theory
would say this no more than 20 percent
in any one sector no more than five
percent in any one position that has
been a standard in the indexing market
for Sovereign wealth and pension plans
for a hundred years and I abide by those
rules in most of the mandates that I'm
involved in managing with the exception
of real estate in our operating company
our Holdings in real estate now are 39
percent which is significantly it's a
heavy overweighting and the majority of
that is in Florida where we have are
very positive and constructive about the
demographics that are occurring there
now I've heard all the arguments about
Miami sinking underwater and I get all
that we've been talking about that for
100 years and there is always that risk
in any Coastal investment but when you
look at the demographics and demand for
properties and office property in South
Beach or Miami proper or Brickell or
even Palm Beach or other West Palm Beach
and other areas where I am an investor
we see this continuing and on an ongoing
basis and I have to thank the
politicians in New York and
Massachusetts and California for this
wonderful investment opportunity because
this is why prices there have not
corrected and why they continue to be
very very buoyant and demand remains
strong the harder you make it to start a
business in New York the better it is
for me in Miami and so you know that's
the bottom line and and I I talked to
Mayor Suarez every day and all the other
politicians there they are very open to
business they understand the advantage
they have they're running around the
world with their arms open and it's on
top of all that we've got the crypto
Community which some people think is
going to be the 12th sector of the
economy in a decade and I agree with
that theory
centered one of the global centers now
is Miami so I spend about five six
months a year there just dealing in that
sector
so you're you have roughly twice your
typical sector allocation now allocated
to real estate you said 39 obviously
mortgage rates have increased from Two
and a half percent in December to now on
average over seven percent which is
remarkable and potentially indicates
that buyer purchasing power should go
down by about 45 not necessarily to say
that real estate prices would fall by
that but it does look like there is an
inflection point housing prices have
started to fall since about uh march to
May uh what's your take on how deep this
correction can go you've got you know
some folks screaming we've got a 50
coming and then the counter argument is
this is no 2008 lending standards are
too strong maybe we're in for a you know
average 15 correction where do you stand
we haven't seen a 15 correction in any
markets yet there's fundamental demand
obviously and the consumer remains
buoyant but you're right we could have
that traditionally the real estate cycle
used to be seven years that has gone we
haven't had a significant correction I
don't care what Market in North America
you look at for 25 years and that's
because of change of demographic and
demand for housing both rental and
assumed ownership but you know you gotta
you got to look at it this way real
estate Cycles
um are really interest rate sensitive as
you've detailed but these these mortgage
rates right now are still traditionally
very low if you go over a 40 50 year
period I've been an investor in real
estate when interest rates are 15 one
five I've been an investor when mortgage
rates are under four and so at the end
of the day fundamental shelter and
housing and office space and demand
industrially demand for Real Estate
remains a constant in any economy at
different levels of trajectory but as an
asset class it has proven to be buoyant
for hundreds of years you know the old
adage they stopped making it a long time
ago particularly that applies to
beachfront properties and vacation
properties and look what's happening in
Montana look what's happened in North
Dakota look what's happened to Farmland
these are all Investments that I look at
every day you know each of them have
their own merits or risks there's no
question about it but at the end of the
day it's a fundamental building block in
anybody's portfolio and the only
decision you have to make when you're
young is how much debt do I want to take
on and that's governed by the percentage
of that mortgage and so you're right if
mortgage rates go past seven percent and
I think the terminal rate on the FED
will be under five so you could see some
high-risk mortgages mortgages at seven
that's still traditionally not a very
high mortgage rate
now some would argue that uh look last
time we had 15 mortgage rates the the
median home price was maybe 80 to 120
000 now we're sitting at 400 000 around
four times that do you think that we
could be more sensitive because of these
higher prices uh and then also sort of a
part two to that you mentioned we
haven't seen a significant correction in
25 years what about 08
that's true but it was a very very short
period 18 months and so when you think
about an asset class like real estate it
is a very slow turn asset class the
entry and exit fees are very high you
don't flip it you don't trade it you
really have to think about the cap rate
is reflecting and but I would agree with
your statement in 08 with with the
financial crisis was cap rates went up
and so it's the inverse so if you buy a
building at four and a half percent cap
rate which was AAA office Towers in
Boston you know hey yeah they spiked up
a bit for that 18 months but there were
very few trades in that market so you
know these assets people think very long
term on now I would agree there's a new
reason to consider cap rates going up in
Industrial and Commercial Real Estate
that's because of new trend in work
environments which are not so focused on
office anymore for most companies now
they have flexibility and up to a third
or half of their employees never come
back to the office and that's is
probably permanent particularly in
sectors like technology so that may put
some pressure on cap rates for
commercial which means their values go
down if cap rates are up the building's
worth less however in the case of
residential the inverse is true because
all of a sudden you've got rural
communities like Champaign Urbana and
places where people want to live raise
their kids go to good schools get more
house for the dollar those cap rates are
the cost of those houses have gone up
and the cap rates have gone down because
all of a sudden you don't have to live
in Chicago you can live in Champaign
Urbana and the lifestyle there on
greencroft Avenue right on the golf
course where I used to live a long time
ago that's a beautiful place to raise a
family and you can still participate in
the Chicago community
wow wow that's that's a very good point
uh so some real demographic changes
there so uh what what advice would you
have for for scaling sort of a
single-family portfolio would you be
following the jobs would you uh avoid
any particular would you avoid
short-term rentals what what what's your
take on that no I do a blend I like your
idea of a blended portfolio I like a
real diversification of duration when
you do rental deals you want
diversification just in case rents go up
then you have the ability to reset them
at a higher rate if they're shorter term
but that's all part of the portfolio
analysis I do however prefer putting in
my investments into business friendly
states where you've got the constant
amount of entrepreneurs starting
businesses which will bring you more and
more customers I mean customer
acquisition is what you care about in
real estate portfolio so I prefer places
like Florida like Texas like Montana
like North Dakota any state that is
pro-business that is not raising its
taxes past 50 percent because as that is
just the breaking point remember when
you pay 52 tax that's the money you
can't pay for your rent because you're
giving it to a poorly managed government
who goes and wastes it up for you that's
what's happening in Massachusetts that's
what's happening in New York there's a
reason these places are uncompetitive
look at San Francisco walk around
downtown that is a war zone Los Angeles
a war zone it's a complete collapse in
society because what they've done is
they've broken management they have no
way of managing those anymore they've
squandered their resources they've
squandered their money California is a
disaster great place to visit wonderful
to take that drive down the highway but
I wouldn't touch it as an investment and
at night my goodness I wouldn't wear any
of my watches out that place is I
wouldn't even walk in San Francisco at
night it is literally a war zone you
wouldn't recognize it anymore
I I got so lucky you know I bought uh I
almost bought in February of 2020 I
almost bought one of those painted
ladies that you saw in the intro of Full
House uh there's those row houses
uh a complete Fixer-Upper and uh I would
have been locked down forever and not
been able to do anything on that project
because covet hit right after uh it
turns out that seller who beat me by
five thousand dollars like three and a
half mil uh tried reselling it uh
permits approved two years and five
hundred thousand dollars later just for
paperwork tried selling it for what she
paid for it after having spent five
hundred thousand dollars and had to
delist it after six months because
nobody would buy it no I agree I mean
this you think about that that market
has suffered because of policy Bad
Decisions by government bad overall
policy and then of course the collapse
of society nobody wants to invest in a
war zone and I would argue uh Los
Angeles and and and San Francisco they
are modern day war zones if you like
that video where do you see my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe